nous avons une vive préoccupation celle
du service public de la justice
le service public de la justice est en
crise le service public de la justice
est en grande souffrance
nous avons constaté que les délais de
jugement ne cesse de s'allonger
les peines sont mal exécutée les prisons
sont saturés une réforme a été engagée
pour répondre à ces difficultés
cette réforme a suscité une hostilité
sans précédent de toutes les professions
de justice
nous les avons réunis hier en tables
rondes elles attendent plus de garanties
pour les droits des justiciables
elles attendent aussi plus de garanties
que la couverture de chacun de notre
territoire sera correctement assuré le
sénat partage intégralement ses
préoccupations ils vous demandent ils
demandent au gouvernement de bien
vouloir suspendre les travaux
parlementaires pour trouver un accord
qui permettra de faire en sorte que une
réponse appropriée pertinentes et
consensuelle soit apportée aux
préoccupations du monde de la justice
partagé par nos collectivités
la parole les communistes en charge des
relations avec le parlement
monsieur fesneau
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
président bah je voudrais tout d'abord
excusé l'absence de la garde des sceaux
qui s'est rendu auprès des personnels
pénitentiaires à tarascon après
l'évasion intervenue en début de semaine
vous m'interrogez sur vous interroger le
gouvernement sur la réforme de la
justice qui est en cours aujourd'hui à
un stade avancé de la navette
parlementaire je sais que vous avez
organisé comme vous l'avez rappelé une
table ronde d'hier avec plusieurs
organisations du monde de la justice et
que vous avez également invité madame la
garde des sceaux à venir s'exprimer
devant la commission des lois ce qu'elle
a fait également hier au cours des
débats parlementaires qui se sont tenues
depuis octobre dernier on a pu observer
des points de convergence réelle autour
d'un objectif commun donner enfin à la
justice les moyens auxquels elle peut
pétant prétendre et la réforme et pour
prendre en compte les besoins des
justiciers monsieur le président pas
vous annonce vous disiez à juste titre
qu'il y avait une vraie urgence sur la
justice et de ce fait je comprends moins
d'une certaine façon votre expression à
demander finalement une pause parce
qu'il ya besoin et vous avez raison de
le dire d'une réforme profonde de la
justice qui répondent aux besoins des
justiciables
ces besoins sont ceux d'une justice de
proximité qui soit efficace et moderne
qui soit plus rapide et vous avez raison
de le rappeler et qui protège les
français tout en garantissant leurs
doigts sur les moyens d'atteindre ces
objectifs le sénat et l'assemblée
nationale ont divergé votre assemblée
partie d'une position qu'elle avait été
qu'elle avait élaboré dès le printemps
2017 et qui ne correspondaient pas au
choix à la fois fait part le gouvernant
après la consultation organisée dans le
cadre des chantiers de la justice au
cours de l'examen par l'assemblée
nationale le texte a évolué démontrant
l'ouverture du gouvernement et de la
majorité sur ce sujet je voudrais vous
rappeler que alors que le projet initial
prévoyait une répartition des
juridictions sur la carte administrative
qui est telle qu'elle était prévue il a
été décidé par le gouvernement après
écoute des élus et des professions
judiciaires de choisir le menthe de
maintien du maillage territorial de
justice tel qu'il avait été prévu si
vous dire si notre souhait constant
c'est de faire en sorte que la justice
soit écoutée et que les moyens soient
donnés la réforme arrive un stade de la
navette où le texte semble se dessiner
définitivement je ne doute pas que le
travail du sénat permettrait un certain
nombre de dispositions et c'est donc
avec cet esprit là que nous abordons la
dernière les
sur qui va se dérouler désormais au
sénat je remercie monsieur le président
bat seul ministre regrette de vous dire
que cet esprit est un esprit de
fermeture on ne peut pas avoir raison
seul contre tout le monde
on ne peut pas réformer la société par
voie d'autorité c'est très rare que les
greffiers les magistrats les avocats
soient tous d'accord c'est très rare
qu'une assemblée comme le sénat et
trouver des points de convergence qui
coïncide avec les attentes manifesté par
les professions de justice et je crois
que le gouvernement serait bien inspiré
après les troubles des derniers mois de
commencer à comprendre qu'une autre
méthode est préférable si on veut
réformer la société en profondeur
il faut d'abord recherché par le
dialogue davantage de consensus c'est ce
que nous vous offrons de faire en
essayant de dégager nous mêmes des
points d'accord avec les professions de
justice
[Applaudissements]